I just wanna clarify
some things before we,
before we get started.
Every woman is not built
for the great responsibility
of being a First Lady.
Pastor Lee-Curtis
Childs faces
allegations of misconduct.
His Mega Church may
never be the same.
Lee-Curtis and I,
we're gonna get
to the other side.
You there.
Yeah, with the big
ole microphone.
Come in closer, son.
You gon' see what
all the fuss is about.
Show time.
♪ What's up ♪
♪ Fresh is our return, baby ♪
is a talent, a star.
Lee-Curtis
Oh boy.
Ah, we can edit
around that? Right?
This is going to chronicle
the ultimate comeback.
I'm Rocky up in this fight.
Rocky didn't win.
But he did win in Rocky 2.
Lord, baby, how many
times I gotta tell you?
Get past the first movie.
That was all a set up.
♪ Can't pay my rent ♪
He is just so raw.
He needs someone
to harness it all.
Oh, bless your heart.
I'm sure plenty of
the old congregation
on back through.
will come right
Good ole Wander
the Greater Paths' door
You have a blessed one.
Oh my goodness,
and you have a blessed...
I'm a sinner, but
I'm no criminal.
We need you back
in that pulpit.
So, you can get me
back on that stage.
You ain't really getting
that many beeps, baby!
Shake it for the Lord!
That's it! Get it!
Yeah!
For the Lord!
Get my honks, for the Lord!
All those folks out there
who are gonna see this,
I want them to know,
was supposed to do.
that I did what
how that's possible.
I just don't see
possible with God.
All things are
That, that's Matthew 19:26.
Yes it is.
So, that's good.
You can cut.